have you ever considered um something
that
i think that's been dope lately is
um artists doing full projects with
producers right so like
freddy did mad lib [ __ ] then he did the
alchemist project conway did a whole
project with alchemist
um i think it'd be super dope to just
hear you do it just lock in with with
one producer
cohesive album is that something you've
ever considered
you know it's crazy with that i got like
maybe three of those in the works right
now like i just ain't
like all the way like got in that bag
just because of the other music i'm
working on
but um shout outs to mike and keys we
doing the project just they producing
the whole thing
they actually did um handsome and menace
off comma three
um i linked up with them doing that yep
um
a rap music we got maybe seven records
i mean it's just straight a rap you know
i mean and um
buddha and grants that's my home team
they did
been working doing all my [ __ ] for years
so i was gonna say i would like
maybe three different tapes i i think yo
you gotta like
i would just love to hear you lock in
just with like
just nothing but just you know razor
blades on ikea [ __ ] plates and beats
ikea or like maybe like no who ain't got
where yet that i'm dying to get
out i was gonna say i was gonna say an
alchemist project said
but i've been done like even i've been
in tune with them tape like i love them
tapes
action bronson was doing with him oh my
god you know what i'm saying like all
them tapes was
just the way he put a project together
action was really good at working with
whole producers because he would do some
[ __ ] with party supplies
or yeah i'm producing and then like yeah
but you know what it is with me i feel
like
that would that would make an ill sound
just because i've always
had three beats from this producer two
beats from this producer one from this
but like it's always been a mixture
you know i mean so that's definitely
something i'm gonna do that's something
i'm working on now but that's coming up
do you have a relationship with
alchemist yeah yeah oh my god you know
that'll be big man i'll cause my girl
have you and primo ever work together
yep
primo's on the end show of survival oh
that's right that's right yeah yeah we
talked about that yeah but he didn't do
the beat right he just did the
scratching he did the scratching but we
got some we got
me and primo i think i had two raccoons
because i i went to his studio to
do actually do a record for survival um
and we laid that but then once i got the
record and the rest of the songs for the
album
it just it didn't mesh but um yeah
pretty much that's the big bro
oh yeah when when you like uh when it's
a primo b do you feel the same type of
expectations as like
as as as as if you know it's like you're
getting on a record with nas
exactly same like that's what i feel
like
made me push my pen earlier in my career
i mean like once i got people who knew
about me like i was working with certain
people i was like i got the rap i got to
you know i'm saying i got to come with
it each time i'm being heard i got to
come with it
so um definitely with certain producers
like i grew up to all of that
this is all people that i was reading in
the source magazine
you know what i'm saying so now when
they fans at me and i mean and they let
me know that what i'm doing is dope
i got to try to like exceed that
expectation like even more
i mean i